So years ago, while I was working at a company that shall not be named,
I was bored out of my mind, and one of the things that people at this company
did to pass the time was playing Tetris.
I ended up liking this Tetris game so much
that I decided to try and write my own version of it,
write a computer program to play Tetris, and if you haven't seen it before,
Tetris is a Soviet falling blocks puzzle game
with a number of different pieces, all of which are made up of 4 smaller blocks.
I decided that I wanted to support not just the normal Tetris pieces,
but because I'm a bit of a math person, the ability to have pieces
that were 5 long as well.
In order to do that, I ended up making a piece definition language,
a way of writing out what a Tetris piece should look like
that this Tetris program would then read in.
Now, I didn't use all of the lexing and parsing techniques
that you're going to learn in this class,
but I did use the same sort of concepts, and the point I'm trying to get across here
is that in some sense, learning how to create
your own language is like learning how to read.
It really opens up a world of possibilities.
It's a new tool in your belt that will come up and help you
when you least expect it.